a lot of people think the big news
stories these days are well a judge
ruling against snooping by the NSA or
the big fight in Congress over the new
proposed budget a lot of people say
those are the big stories but judging by
local news and I've been looking at a
lot of local news there's an even bigger
story that's sweeping the nation right
now who are you really shopping for this
holiday season it's ok you can admit it
if you've bought an item or two or ten
for yourself
well it's ok you can admit it if you
have bought an item or two or maybe ten
for yourself it's ok you can admit it
you've bought number two or ten for
yourself it's ok you can admit it if you
borrow my number two or ten for yourself
ok you can admit it if you bought an
item or two or ten for yourself it's ok
you can admit it
if you spot an item or two or ten for
yourself it's ok you can admit it Todd
if you've bought an item or two or ten
for your cell phone okay you've been a
minute if you've owned an item or two or
ten for yourself it's okay you can admit
it if you'd like I don't know item or
two or maybe ten for yourself okay you
can admit it
for yourself it's okay you could admit
it if you bought one or two or maybe
three or four maybe even ten items for
yourself it's okay you can admit it if
you bought an item or two or ten for
yourself
it's okay you can admit it item 210 for
yourself
it's okay you can admit if you bought an
item or two or ten for yourself
it's okay you can admit it if you bought
an item or two or maybe ten for yourself
it's okay
but maybe an item of two or ten for
yourselves and okay you can admit it
if you've bought an item or two or three
or ten for yourself that's okay
you can admit to one of ten for yourself
and it's okay you can you get it if you
brought an item or two or ten for you
it's okay admit if you've bought an item
if you want an item or two or ten for
yourself it's okay you can admit it okay
say for yourself it's okay
or temper yourself
it's okay you can minute if you bought
yourself with one or two or ten things
for yourself because a lot of people do
it
[Applause]
scary I find it frightening